[Music]
on this saturday night home at last
the two michaels land on canadian soil
it's such an
immense relief to be back in canada in
what appears to be a hostage swap the
two sets of cases are very much
interrelated and politically motivated
will this thought china-canada relations
under investigation the serious
allegations facing canada's military
police and president biden faces
backlash after expelling thousands of
haitian migrants
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us after nearly three years of
imprisonment in china michael kovrick
and michael spavor are back in canada
the two landed at calgary international
airport early this morning where they
were greeted on the tarmac by prime
minister justin trudeau kovrik continued
on to toronto where he was reunited with
his wife and sister the two men were
jailed in what's widely seen as
retaliation for the arrest of huawei
executive mangwon zhou the canadians
were on a plane at almost the exact same
time mung left vancouver after reaching
a deal with u.s prosecutors jeff semple
has more on the joyous homecoming
after 1020 days in detention in china
michael kovrig is finally home i feel
great frankly i feel fantastic
it's such an
immense relief to be back in canada to
be here home with my family again
i feel like i'm on top of the world and
i'm just immensely grateful
to everyone who has been working so hard
for these over a thousand days to bring
both me and michael spaver home
it's fantastic thank you so much and i'm
really looking forward to
the future with my family he and michael
spavor landed early this morning first
in calgary where they were embraced by
the canadian prime minister and even
seen sharing a laugh
from there kovrik traveled onwards to
toronto met on the tarmac by his sister
and his wife veena najibullah
speaking to global news just hours after
arriving in toronto his first day home
after nearly three years in a chinese
prison cell kovrig seemed full of life
even cracking jokes and he also wanted
to say thanks
i didn't know most of what was happening
in the outside world but all the the
knowing that so many canadians and
others were aware
of our situation and sending messages of
support
really meant a lot to us
so thank you thank everybody for that
those comments echoed by his wife vina
who led the family's fight to bring him
home for the first time in a long time
she was smiling ear to ear
immense gratitude we're happy he's here
it's
been a thousand and twenty days of
working for this moment the moment is
here i am so grateful to everybody
ambassador barton canadian government us
government everybody who work to make
this day happen
and to all canadians who have been with
us every step of the way i'm just still
learning how to breathe again because i
feel like i've been holding my breath
for
almost three years
so
yeah that's about that kevin and julia
garrett know the feeling the canadians
were detained in china in 2014 under
similar circumstances and remember what
it was like to hug someone for the first
time in years
yeah and just thinking about all the
firsts like just imagining their family
hugging and that that moment of just
coming together and the first drink of
coffee that you can go get by yourself i
remember waking up for the very first
morning after i arrived
and uh you know i just wanted a coffee
until starbucks opened which was nearby
where we were staying and uh walking in
there getting a coffee and seeing my
face on the front page of the paper
thinking why is that there
it came out of nowhere yeah i i really
didn't expect in my wildest dreams that
it would happen michael spavor's friends
in south korea were supposed to meet up
with him in seoul at their favorite pub
the night he was arrested so i look
forward to taking him back there and and
reliving old times
also touched down this morning in china
beijing had long insisted her case was
not connected to the two michaels but
mong's plane passed the michaels in the
sky their departures coming just minutes
apart
i think
it it just goes on to show that the two
sets of cases are very much interrelated
and politically motivated are you
surprised though that they didn't make
more of an effort to
make it look like these cases weren't
connected
actually on reflection not really
american john kam has spent 30 years
advocating for political prisoners in
china including the two michaels he says
beijing no longer shows much concern for
its image in the west
china is i think less concerned about
its image that's not to say they're
totally
unconcerned i think they are concerned
when it
suits their purpose to be concerned for
now the families are less interested in
geopolitics and more in taking some time
together for them and their countless
canadian supporters a much needed happy
ending and the beginning of the road to
recovery
jeff semple global news toronto
let's bring in our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson who is also the host
of the west block and the west block was
invited to speak with michael coffrey
and his family first of all how is he
doing
just um amazing as as you heard a little
bit about in jeff's piece there robin he
was smiling he was joking about being
well rested
but you could just feel the energy and
the radiance from this family that are
so relieved to finally have their loved
one home i asked his wife vina what it
was like when she saw him coming off the
plane and how that felt take a listen to
this
what was the moment like when you first
saw michael stepping off the plane and
you were able to embrace him
hard to describe indescribably intense
let's just say and leave it at that
thank you
thank you yes
i think
we just need some time now to heal and
to rest but thank you so much mercedes
and everyone thank you
mercedes how did his release develop was
there a deal did he give any indication
of that
well we don't really know and you know
today the family and and michael really
just wanted to talk a little bit about
being home of course we will be asking
all those questions but in terms of
questions we've asked the government
that's something we're trying to pursue
and we have the foreign minister mark
garno joining us on the show tomorrow to
talk a little bit more about this we do
know obviously the main deal was from
the u.s government and that was to drop
the extradition request for mong wong
zhou who then went home but obviously
there was a connection to the two
michaels and what was surprising to
everyone who's been covering this case
is how quickly they actually were able
to be released and come home
there was a lesser essentially plea deal
that was expected with mong long joe
initially the department of justice had
wanted her to plead guilty on a bunch of
things whether or not there was a deal
cut to get the michaels out more quickly
and get what she wanted we'll try to
find out but certainly today everyone
just celebrating the fact that the two
michaels are home
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes and mercedes will have more of
that conversation tomorrow on the west
block right here on global
the canadian military is being accused
of covering up an investigation
involving a member of the military
police and tonight there are calls for
the military police to be disbanded our
ottawa correspondent michael couture has
been following this story mike
robin we have few details of where the
alleged incident happened and who it
involved but we do know from a statement
posted online by the military police
complaints commission announcing the
watchdog is investigating whether there
was a deliberate attempt by military
police
to cover up quote misconduct by one of
their own if you can't trust the
military police
there's some serious issues with the
chain of command and the the image of
the military police as a whole stu
kellock is a former military police
officer who also served in senior roles
with the toronto police department he
has serious concerns about the military
justice system and says this latest
incident is just another example of how
the system is broken according to the
online statement a military police
officer who appeared intoxicated put her
children in her car and allegedly
attempted to drive them and herself home
after leaving a restaurant bystanders
stopped her local police arrived and
alerted military police after learning
she was an officer the military force
took it from there according to the
military police complaints commission
there have been serious issues with the
investigation that followed in a
statement the mpcc said these complaints
allege that the mp unit's leadership
attempted to cover up the alleged
misconduct of an officer of that unit
and improperly giving special treatment
to the mp officer involved it undermines
the confidence in the credibility of
those who are supposed to have the
highest ethical moral and legal
standards in the entire canadian forces
the complaints about the investigation
allege the military police investigators
electronic report was altered without
their knowledge and unit members were
threatened not to report the incident
the timing is definitely not very
advantageous for
an armed forces that are trying to
re-establish some credibility generally
and specifically in terms of how they
can deal with investigations in a
statement a spokesperson for the
military police told global news no one
has been suspended in relation to this
case but the military police
professional standards section is
monitoring this file and communicating
with the complaints commission
robin mike look at you in ottawa thanks
mike
u.s customs officials are reopening a
border crossing in texas after a
makeshift migrant encampment was cleared
away as many as 15 000 people mostly
haitians had amassed there in hopes of
seeking asylum but about 2 000 migrants
were put on deportation flights to haiti
as jennifer johnson reports president
joe biden is facing backlash over how
the administration handled this
situation the before and after pictures
are startling last week over 15 000
haitians most who had been living in
south america packed a border encampment
in del rio texas on friday it was empty
thousands of the migrants now face
immigration judges or are voluntarily
returning to mexico fearing they'll be
deported what we do when we see
something that is unprecedented is we
respond and respond we did
the biden administration is facing heavy
criticism for border patrol agents
heavy-handed tactics and trying to stop
the haitian migrants some photos appear
to show border agents trying to whip
them even members of president joe
biden's own party are angry the white
house continues to be silent as far as
far as the humane treatment of the
migrants that i witnessed down there
president biden has broken that silence
promising an investigation of the
aggressive treatment and a new ban on
agents on horseback in del rio of course
i take responsibility i'm president but
i was horrible what to see as you saw to
see people treat it like they did horses
running over people being strapped it's
outrageous the biden administration is
also facing backlash for flying two
thousand haitians back to their country
under new pandemic rules the u.s special
envoy to haiti daniel foote resigned in
protest
criticism too from new york city council
member farrell lewis whose district is
home to a large haitian community it's
political chaos it's just chaos it's not
safe for anyone and they're going back
knowing that they have nothing to go
back to these people have given up
everything now their futures are
uncertain including for 10 babies born
at the camp despite dire conditions no
lives were lost this time law
enforcement officials believe another
caravan of about 20 thousand migrants is
in south mexico and heading to del rio
jennifer johnson global news washington
the era of angela merkel is ending
coming up how the german chancellor will
be remembered
the volcano on spain's la palma island
is entering an explosive new phase on
friday officials say volcanic
measurements recorded the highest energy
activity from the eruption so far a new
emission vent has also formed along the
volcano ash has now forced the island's
only airport to close though ferries are
still available for travel nearly 6 000
people on the island have been forced to
leave
tomorrow germans head to the polls to
choose the country's next leader angela
merkel's successor in the center-right
christian democratic union is neck and
neck in the polls with the candidate
from the center-left socialist
democratic party whoever wins will have
some big shoes to fill merkel was
influential in shaping policy well
beyond her country's borders so the race
to replace her is being closely watched
redmond shannon looks at the legacy she
leaves behind
angela merkel is believed to be
terrified of dogs in 2007 vladimir putin
brought his black labrador to a meeting
with her
clearly uncomfortable she was still able
to joke about it in fluent russian
those who have followed merkel's career
say her ability to engage putin is
partly down to her early life in
communist east germany putin who's often
tried to outsmart her has come to
respect her
because she's somebody who hasn't been
bowled over somebody who who sort of
knows his game from from the inside
merkel has worked with four u.s
presidents most closely with barack
obama chancellor merkel has been an
outstanding partner obama's visit to
germany in the days after donald trump's
election victory reportedly inspired
merkel to seek a fourth term the leader
of the free world was considered to be
an angeles because she was the one who
who through her focus on on
pragmatism was the one who could stand
up to uh to trump i have german in my
blood
i'll be there merkel and trump's
leadership styles could barely have been
more different she has a tendency to
sort of
sit down and think the problem through
she was an experimental physicist
quantum chemistry in the wake of the
fukushima nuclear disaster she u-turned
on nuclear power deciding to phase it
out in germany but her analytical method
also had its drawbacks notably during
the eurozone debt crisis a decade ago
there's nothing rational about financial
markets it was the psychological thing
that she missed in her attempt to
make this a rational
solvable problem european austerity
policy supported by merkel made her
unpopular in the countries hit hardest
by the economic crisis many of the same
nations were on the front line of the
2015 refugee crisis perhaps merkel's
greatest legacy was to welcome one
million of those refugees
often does famously saying we can do
this
they did it and voters backed merkel's
moral stand in 2017 although many others
moved to the far right too supporters
and opponents agree that the woman
nicknamed mooty or mother has left a
lasting mark at the center of europe
redmond shannon global news london
still ahead why canadians are about to
see bigger digits on their cell phone
bills
you're watching global national
this week bell announced it's raising
wireless prices for some existing
customers depending on their plans that
can mean your cell phone bill is going
up even if you're a customer with
another provider and gaviola explains
why
at the onset of the pandemic the big
three telecom companies bell telus and
rogers waived roaming charges and
overage fees a nod to how reliant we'd
all become on our wireless devices
during kovid but that grace period ran
out last year and now observers say
we've entered a new era for prices the
government has increasingly started to
side with big telecom companies against
consumers we have a freshly elected
minority government you may recall there
was no mention of cell phone
affordability anywhere in the liberals
89-page platform even though polls
showed the issue is important to voters
this week bell has let some customers
know that price hikes are coming to
certain plans starting in november data
overage rates will jump for them from 10
to 13 per 100 megabytes and long
distance calls within canada and the us
will go from
cents a minute to 75.
telus tells global news its current rate
plan suite doesn't have data overages
and there are no plans to change long
distance data rates within canada and
the us in the foreseeable future rogers
did not respond to a request for comment
but analysts tell global news this is a
definite sign of things to come in the
past the major players have hiked prices
in rapid succession and researchers at
open media say there's no reason to
think that this time around is going to
be any different or that there aren't
more price increases to come and all of
this is happening as wireless prices
around the world continue to fall the
real question we need to be asking
ourselves is is the huge gap between
what canadians pay for mobile and
internet data and what places
other countries pay for it is that gap
shrinking
and it's not we don't see any evidence
that we're making up that ground the
pushback from major carriers is that
they're investing billions in 5g the
next generation of the internet which
will be key for truly unlimited data
plans and things like connected cars and
homes it comes at a cost to consumers
if the big three weren't turning some of
the highest profits of all telecom
companies per customer in the whole
world
it might be more believable but we know
that they are ann gaviola global news
toronto
pandemic pet problems up next the
animals who gave comfort are now being
given away
as many canadians struggled with
isolation pet adoptions were all the
rage early in the pandemic whether small
or fluffy they helped fight off the
loneliness of lockdown but as more
people start traveling and returning to
work many of these cute companions are
now being given away and the worrying
trend has animal welfare groups on high
alert crystal commansing reports
call it creature comfort
shut in by the pandemic people all over
turned to animals
just innocent loving pets that just want
to be loved and that's what i needed too
so it worked out pet adoption spiked
when human contact wasn't an option
linda nguyen says she wouldn't know what
to do without her beloved dogs but for
others priorities are shifting
many are back working at the office
people want to travel
and go out the uk's largest dog welfare
charity has seen traffic on its giving
up your dog page jumped 100 percent in
the past six months calls about
surrendering animals started just after
july 19 when nearly all restrictions in
england were lifted so far dogs aren't
being returned on mass but the group
fears that wave
could be coming
canadian groups such as the toronto
humane society says thankfully it hasn't
seen a similar increase in calls
rehoming pets is incredibly hard in
germany last month one animal group
turned to tinder yet tinder the dating
app the munich animal welfare
association thought maybe someone would
swipe right on a good boy my mittens
says quite simply it's fun this is
something new something creative which
we definitely support
support is something animal shelters are
always looking for the pandemic at first
seemed to lead to so many perfect
matches
now agencies fear they'll need to dream
up even more creative ways to re-home
pandemic pets
even after they provided their humans
with the love and support they needed
crystal gomson global news london
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is a sure sign of fall a red
maple leaf in oakville ontario thank you
for watching good night
[Music]